Russians may have vacated hersen but the
Ukrainian military has still got a lot
of mop-up operations to do in the area
liberating The Villages and the towns
that form in the outskirts the urban
areas also clearing the mines and the
booby traps that we left behind and also
flushing out the Russian soldiers that
were left behind and also that some the
office of Special Forces as well what we
have learned though is a little bit more
about the Russian withdrawal bizarre
scenes on the 9th of November when on
Russian television they showed the
Russian generals discussing and debating
the withdrawal and then ordering it it
turns out now that the decision was made
several weeks earlier to withdraw the
troops from Harrison itself the military
Russian military got changed into
civilian codes and then crossed the
zanipra river under the guise of a
civilian evacuation once they got The
Far Side the river they dug defensive
positions the TV conference with the
generals has almost certainly aimed at
the Russian domestic audience let them
know what was going on as soon as that
happened the last of the soldiers left
the Russians blew the bridges and that
effectively stopped the ukrainians
chasing up and following behind but also
in the news is the donbass Russians are
fighting extreme even harder than ever
up there and it's clearly one of their
main efforts as part of achieving the
objectives of Putin's special military
operation and taking this one remaining
region of the donbass that they don't
currently control the Russians are
pushing hard around bakmuts and making
very limited progress with stoical
Ukrainian resistance ukrainians are
pushing across its photova and actually
into luhansk almost certainly trying to
distract from the Russian effort what we
don't know is the 30 000 Russian troops
that were in Harrison where they're
going to appear next but almost
certainly they're going to be brought up
into the fight and if that happens the
intensity will go up as all the
casualties casualties have been a key
figure over the last week when details
from America suggesting that over a
hundred thousand casualties from both
sides and since the fighting in a
donbass is intensified that will
undoubtedly be increasing for the
Russians particularly their insistence
on you using poorly trained poorly
equipped and poorly motivated soldiers
it's worth reminding viewers that for
every one death on the battlefield
there's normally 10 times as many
serious injuries this Legacy of this war
will be felt for generations to come and
on this Remembrance Day I think it's a
particularly poignant reminder that
devastating human impact for both sides
of Putin's decision to invade Ukraine